that's I think what our message is is
like you gotta keep pushing made money
at this point in his life doesn't have
to be doing podcasts yeah yeah I don't
want to put your business out there but
he could be retired on a yacht chilling
but he believes so much in the mission
that we're working on at valuetainment
that this guy will not stop and
sometimes you need someone like that in
your corner me as an example you know my
goal I was a former South Beach Party
nightlife guy broke crashing on guys
couches and I said wow one day I'm going
to be a millionaire what
35 years old I'm a millionaire I'm like
all right I made it that's it that was
my goal that was my dream money chicks
partying South Beach down I did it right
but sometimes you need someone to look
at you and be like one million dollars
but yeah yeah you know you know that's
where you're stopping that's your vision
that's what you got going on that's the
next level